hello everyone and welcome to a really
insane game from round 11 of the 2018
candidates tournament and I was actually
planning on showing you this game about
four hours ago that's probably that's
probably about the time this game should
have ended but it only ended now and
you'll see how many how many weird
opportunities happen on the board and
how many great opportunities were missed
so it's round 11 at Engler and with the
white pieces against Alexander district
and let's just see this game let's let's
see some of the photos before we do here
we have a nice photo of Greece shook
these are all photos from round 11 here
we have a nice close-up of ding and also
here we have another nice close-up of
Alexander so let's see this game we have
c4 c5 so the English opening symmetrical
variation Knight to f3 Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and Knight to c6 the four
Knights opening old English III isse x
d4 d5 so transposing into the the
symmetrical variation of the Taurus
defense we have a 3d captures on c4
Bishop captures on c4 and now a6
preparing b5 white castles we have b5
Bishop to a2 and Bishop to b7 so both
sides simply developing Queen to e2 now
we have Queen to c7 Bishop to d2 Bishop
to e7 rook to c1
and now c4 locking this Bishop our way
white will reactivate it with Bishop to
be one but black will get a nice outpost
for his night here on b3 so II for rook
to d8 and now Bishop to e3 here we have
Knight to g4 preparing to capture this
Bishop on e3 as this is a it is and will
be a pretty powerful piece and also it
kind of prevents this knight on f3 from
moving for the time being as wink
address and h2 would be a terrible
threat so ii 5 we have Knight to a5 and
this night too if I was premature by
grief
and here a ding really takes his
opportunity to improve the position and
now this was the idea Knight a5 then
coming to b3 but this actually allows
the bishop to f4 and this Bishop to f4
is a massive improvement on on adding
this position as the knight is on a 5
it's no longer attacking the d4 pawn so
white doesn't have to defend it with two
pieces and now Knight captures on e3 is
no longer possible
now the knight on d4 definitely looks a
bit silly and ass wheeler really gave a
nice explanation of why this happens
even in strong Grandmaster games at you
simply think yourself ok at some point I
will definitely capture on e3 and you're
stopped thinking about it then you play
Knight to a5 and you see a move like
Bishop to f4 and now you just
I mean what's what's the knight gonna do
on g4 but ok Queen to b6 now we have
rook C to D 1 defending the d4 pawn has
the Queen attacked it we have h5 and h3
now kicking away the knight Knight has
to go all the way to h6 and now
reactivating this Bishop Bishop to be
one nice to be 3 and now Bishop back to
e3 preparing ideas like d5 would
wouldn't attack on the Queen on b6 so
Queen to c7 getting underway and now
look after he won developing the other
Brooks as well and here now black black
does does have a problem because he
didn't exchange this night for a bishop
on e3 now his knight is terribly placed
on h6 but can't really afford to the
castle here if you Castle simply Bishop
captures on h6 your whole King set is
already busted
it's a terrible position for black so
instead a good issue goes for Kim to f8
here and we have d5 the King is still
coming in the center of the board you
don't want to allow that rook on h8
to get into the game and the position is
definitely full of potential for
attacking so d5 would have a captures on
d5 and now the immediate east 6f
captures only six and now Knight to g5
and already there's a threat of Knight
captures on e6 with the check and the
fork on the Queen this would win the
game immediately and agree should
defends it with Queen to d7
there also was an idea of playing
a person g5 but after Bishop captures on
g5 you're simply you're simply having
too much fun here would White Rock moves
as the rock is attacked and now this
bishop is coming to g6 or you could
simply play a night after Sun d5 there
are too many back rank threats here and
weaknesses so after Knight to g5 Queen
to d7 was played and here
Bishop to g6 and here Bishop to f6 was
played another idea is nice to f5 would
the idea of exchanging a knife for a
bishop now this time for real then maybe
exchanging Bishop for night here
exchanging pieces you know alleviating
alleviating the pressure but after
Knight to f7 attacking both rooks and d4
now attacking Knight and Bishop Bishop
captures Queen captures you'll get
Bishop captures on f5 pawn captures and
now Bishop captures on d4 and blacks
idea was Queen to c6 now threatening
checkmate on g2 but here what has nice
the d5 and white is white is better here
you can't you can never capture here if
you capture you get Queen create
checkmate again back raccoon ranked
weaknesses and district didn't enjoy
this dis variation
so after this Bishop to g6 he didn't go
for Knight to a5 he went Bishop to f6
and here he missed this Bishop to b6
move simply attacking the rook and the
idea is that it doesn't matter that the
knight and g5 is unprotected because
this was a dings idea the idea if Grisha
plays virtual characters on g5 and then
you have bunch of characters and Bishop
captures it seems like you just want to
pieces for a rock but here comes Queen
captures an e6
with the terrible threat of Queen to d8
checkmate after the Queen has exchanged
the rockwool checkmate
then after Queen captures rook captures
again there's the threat of checkmate
here and now after Bishop the blocks now
comes rook captures on d5 again with the
threat of route to d8 check Bishop
captures
check Bishop captures and then again
rook to e8
checkmate so
your characters now Knight captures and
here black is without a move white will
simply capture this Bishop and then
checkmate
the black king or black will simply lose
too much material so a brilliant idea by
ding
so after this Bishop to b6 a greased
Chuck doesn't go for this variation as
he sees the back ranked weaknesses are
too grave rub the c8 was played here we
have Knight captures any sex with check
King to g8 only move on the move that's
not extremely terrible and here we have
Knight captures on d5 Bishop captures on
d5 and this is the critical moment in
the game this is why I say that the game
could have ended right here right now in
this position there are a lot of moves
that are winning but ding plays the one
that's the least winning of them all
here he played Knight to f4 and it it's
it's an interesting move and it also
wins but Bishop totally confused him
here the move that's completely winning
and feel free to pause the video if you
haven't seen the game try to find it I
will show a couple of them there are
winning for those of you who found those
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those of you who want to
enjoy the show here
98 wins the game you simply prevent this
rook from dying d8 square the threat is
once again Queen to e8 followed by Queen
captures and rook captures with
checkmate so after we captured the night
now comes rope capture Sun d5 and black
doesn't have a move if you captured the
rook again simply Queen e8 check this is
checkmate and it doesn't seem that in
that difficult to find because being
displayed this Bishop to g6 obviously
with the idea of putting something on e8
and even if you didn't find the knight
to the 8th then rook captures on d5
immediately is just as winning Queen
captures and now again Knight to d8
simply blocking this rock and Queen to
e8 will again be checkmate and if you
block with Queen e5 it doesn't matter
simply Queen captures Bishop captures
rook captures and again you're
threatening rook to e8 checkmate yeah
after rook captures here Bishop captures
and again you're threatening rock to a
checkmate there is no stopping this so
interesting how ding missed all all of
these ideas but it is round 11 all of
them are very tired but he he is very
young he shouldn't have problems you
know with fatigue but okay he played
Knight to f4 and probably he thought
that this move was just as winning now
there's a double attack on the bishop
here and it definitely seems like black
should just resign here there are simply
too many threats again rook captures
here is coming the threats of Queen to
d8 are still here but here agree should
totally confused him here Grisha played
night the c1 he simply attacked his
Queen on on e2 and you do have to play
something here and now you could simply
capture the night capturing the night
with the rook is winning for white
playing Queen to e3 simply getting the
Queen out of the way also next move you
will capture here you also protect your
Bishop on b6 if if black decides to do
something against that so after night to
d3 getting the night away from c1 not
simply Knight captures on d5 and again
completely winning game for white you
can't capture because again comes Queen
to e8 but after this night to c1 Grisha
completely confused in women and here
Queen captures on h5 was played Knight
to d3 and now Knight captures on d5 but
now it's it's it's a bit different not
nice to f7 and here a Greece should be
yet again confuses dink here Queen to e2
was played by ding but what is again
winning in this position and it's a it's
a force variation so again it's it's
very funny how thing you didn't see it
Knight captures on f6 with Czech pawn
captures and now Bishop captures on f7
which Czech Queen captures and now Queen
to G fourth Czech a very important check
checking the King and I the rook and c8
so only move for you not to lose this
rock is came to h7 and after King to h7
Queen to f5 check now you can't go Queen
g6 because of rook to e7 check you have
to move the King
to g7 you can go to the back back rank
because you again lose the rockin c8 and
here rook to e4 with the idea of rook to
g4 black would have to get this rock
into the game and now rock to g4 check
King moves and now rook to h4 preparing
ideas like rock to h8 King stops and now
comes the Bishop to e3 so now the bishop
will also be able to check the King on
the h8 square rook to d8 getting ready
to move this night and maybe capture on
d1 but now rock to g4 check King f8 and
Bishop to h6 check King to e7 and Queen
rock to g7 this wins the Queen and the
game so it's a pretty long variation 10
moves but all of the ideas are forced
when you see that the Queen from g4 will
be checking the King and I in the rockin
c8 then you do have time to bring the
rock into the game but okay after night
to f7 Queen to d2 was played and here
night F to e 5 Bishop to b4 as now the
bishop has to move from g6 we have
rocked to h4 and F for biding rock
captures on f4 Knight captures on f4 and
Knight characters on f4 with the idea
that if now rook captures Queen then
Knight will capture Queen so first the
bishop to h7 check with the idea that if
King captures Queenie for check and now
black really does lose the Queen so
after Bishop to e2 h7 check came to h8
was played now Queen to e4 the black
Queen is still attacked Queen to c6
offering a trade of Queens and now
Bishop to d4 and here black can black
can play in night e to D 3 with Bishop
captures Queen captures and which was
too powerful Knights place like this the
English ship would definitely have
compensation for the exchange this Queen
can always come to b6 to deliver check
also to b8 will be covering G 1 and H 2
nicely from there but after Bishop to d4
and now gristick goes for Knight
captures on h3 would check with the idea
that if you capture then comes Knight
three check you can't capture it because
the night is protected but this would
also be fine for white but after this
night captures on h3 thing isn't
interest
he plays King to h2 and now night back
to g5 attacking the Queen Queen captures
on c6 rook captures on c6 and now Bishop
to c2 and now out of all that mess you
have a you have a an ending where ding
is up the exchange but the glyph ship is
up a pawn and his pieces are very active
so white what is slightly better here
but from being in a completely winning
position on that move when he could have
played night to the 8th it's really it's
really a hard blow for ding especially
when he sees what he did here at night
the g2 f7 was played you could also play
Knight G to f3 check which the idea I
did if pawn captures now Knight captures
King moves and now you have a problem if
Knight captures anyone would check rook
captures you don't have the option of
playing but it captures on d4 it does
seem to be like a great move because you
get a rook to e8 again checkmate so a
lot of a lot of rook to e8 checkmate
ideas in this game so after Bishop to c2
Knight G to f7 Bishop captures on e5
Knight captures on e5 and now rook to d5
rock to e6 only move as the knight was
attacked King to h3 we have came to g8
b3 now King to f7
be captures on c4 Knight captures on c4
rook to d7 check Bishop to e7
and now rook captures on e6 in captures
and rook to a7 so a lot of
simplifications we have Knight captures
on a three row captures on a6 which
check King to d5 and now Bishop to h7
Knight to c4 King to g4 and now Bishop
to f6
rook to a7 and now King to d4 and now
you'll see that although White's still
have the exchange the dark square Bishop
black has will be completely
compensating for the exchange
Bishop to G we have Knight to d6 King to
f3 now King comes
five rook to e8 before King to e2 and
now Bishop to c3 and I see that the
bishop from c3 is protecting the
opponent before also protecting the pawn
on g7 both of these points are on dark
squares so white can't challenge them
with the bishop and the white can never
capture them with the rook because the
bishop will simply captures rook so it's
impossible to win this position but
Dingley did have much better position
and he definitely wants to try so he
will try a king the three we have came
to b6 came to e3 King to c6 came to a
for now he will try to bring his king of
the board night to b7 King to a
five-night back to c5g for now I think
the b5 g v b3 acting to g6 now comes Kim
King two before Bishop to d5 Bishop to
d4 King to h7 King to c3 g6 now punk
comes all the way to be to and now
better to a2 you do have to prevent the
pawn from being promoted kink the c2 and
now rook to b8 we have Knight to e4 rook
to be four now you definitely don't want
to allow this rook to capture your
bishop so nice to see three now you
can't allow it because now if rook
captures and the Knight captures Bishop
then black will obviously Queen his pawn
faster so Bishop to e6 now what's the
idea that if you promote now then you
have this check here picking up the pawn
so King to see one getting out of the
light square and out Bishop to a5 simply
guarding b1 Bishop to e5
we have rook to b7 be one with Queen
Bishop captures Knight captures and rook
captures on g7 now of course you don't
want to capture the rook if you captured
the rook then this pawn will win the
game
so nice to see three but basically
blacks plan is simple he has this entire
diagonal to simply use and move his
bishop so whenever the white rook
attacks the bishop the bishop will
simply move and the white can never win
this game but the king will still try we
have Knight to c3
Bishop rook to e7 Bishop to d4 now rook
to d7 attacking the bishop
to e5 King to h6 team - see - now comes
King g5 King b3 King to f5 Bishop
Pritchett and rook to b7 check and this
was a very interesting attempt by the
England now if for example if aggressive
tried King to see four here then King to
see four wouldn't need to lose the game
because now you have rook to h7
attacking the bishop the only square
available for the bishop is d4 and now
we'll pin it here rope to h4 the the
bishop is pinned and the King can march
forward if you move the King simply rook
captures keen captures and now the g7
pawn is winning so a very nice attempt
it was already about six and a half
hours maybe six hours and forty minutes
since this game started so definitely a
valiant attempt maybe we should pull
blunder but he does a king c2 rock to h7
now bishop moves came to e6 a king b3
rook to d7 bishop trade sheet rock to d8
Bishop to g7 came to f7 Bishop to e5
rook to e8 Bishop to d4 still a lot of
attempts here rook to be seven Bishop to
e5 rook to b6 Bishop to d4 roof to have
six now blocking the bishops at coverage
of the g7 square but simply Bishop
captures this was all calculated by
Grisha King captures Knight to d5 check
we have King to f7 and night to e3 and
this night to e3 is the only move that
saves black any other move losses so
night to e3 which the idea that if you
push g7 now you get Knight to a5 simply
threatening to capture the pawn and if
you promote it to Queen then come
knowledge six check and you lose the
Queen King moves captures captures and
the game is drawn so after night - III
didn't ride King to have 16 is simply
stopping the night but now comes Knight
to d5 check and again if you attack the
knight you get Knight to f4 check
picking up the pawn so here King to f7
was played again Knight back to e3 g7
and after Knight to f5 they finally drew
the game so yeah the variation is
identical black will capture or
promotion here and then I to h6 check
picks up the Queen so yeah that's the
game
Barenaked Kings unmoved 99 okay the game
didn't last to moon 99 it was not this
Knight to f5 it was a move 96 so 96
moves instead of instead of game that
could have ended in like a miniature but
yeah that's that's the curse of giri it
seems like in round 11
ding clear once again drew his game and
he is three games away from from pulling
a giri which could you know which could
be catastrophic every every drawn game
from then we'll probably be referred to
as the ding which was now a giri but
yeah that's that's just you know things
happen so yeah I mean I do hope you
enjoyed it it was an excellent game and
it was a game that lasted for over 7
hours 7 7 hours and 20 minutes I believe
or something like that I mean totally
crazy so yeah once again I would like to
thank you all for for what for watching
and the once again thanks Nikki for
photos from this from this event the
2080 candidates tournament as usual all
of all the links to our social media
will be in the description below feel
free to check out some of our work and
yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another game from the candidates and
that will show you the final standings
after round 11 in that video thank you
all and I'll see you soon